Here's some foods I made today
as a mom who has three young children
and wants her family to have optimal health.
Started off the morning making overnight fermented
freshly milled iron corn pancakes
served with raw butter
and a fried egg from our pasture raised chickens out back.
At 8:00am I made myself an omelet
using two eggs from my pasture raised chickens
along with some leftover salad from dinner.
I wanted to surprise my kids with cinnamon rolls
when they came back from school today,
so around noon I shaped sourdough pumpkin cinnamon rolls
and let those rise for about two hours.
I also made a large batch of mayonnaise
to have on hand for lunch boxes for a few weeks
to use in tomorrow's chicken salad.
At four PM I quickly prepped a whole chicken
which only took 10 minutes
and then stuck it in the oven for dinner.
After that came out of the oven,
I allowed it to rest while getting started on my corn tortillas.
While my Kamal heated, I mixed masaharina with water,
then kneaded it on the counter until smooth.
Then I made small rounds and flattened each with a tortilla press,
then cooked them for about 45 seconds per side.
Around 5:45 I dressed the salad with a light vinaigrette
and served the kids and husband tacos,
myself a chicken salad, and at 7:30 I started a bone broth.